j'affirme que le piratage est le premier
concurrent de Canal+ en France et dans
le monde la destruction de valeur est
massive pour un acteur de Payet TV a
fortiori dans un modèle généraliste au
présent à la fois sur le sport le cinéma
et l'audiovisuel
Canal+ tire son propre bilan positif de
la mobilisation du niveau dispositif
issu de l'article 3 notamment en termes
de recrutement d'abonnés groupe Canal+ a
obtenu 8 ordonnances permettant le
blocage de site de live streaming et
Lego depuis janvier 2022
c'est en fait une est en cours trois
décisions sont désormais inactives
puisque les compétitions sont arrivées à
leur terme il s'agit des saisons passées
du Top 14 de la Ligue des Champions et
de la première ligue 5 décisions sont
actives ou en cours celles sur la moto
GP celle sur la Formule 1 qui sont
actives jusqu'en novembre celles sur les
saisons en cours de la première ligue du
Top 14 et de la Ligue des Champions
au total depuis le début de l'année 2022
Canal+ a obtenu le blocage de 171 sites
par le biais des premières décisions ces
décisions étaient mises à jour pendant
la compétition viennent quarantaine de
saisines d'actualisation que nous
formulons auprès de la com ces nouvelles
saisies n'ont permis au total le blocage
à ce jour de près de 500 noms de domaine
et probablement 600 d'ici à la fin de
l'année outre la baie significative de
l'audience décide de live streaming que
nous avons appelé tout à l'heure nous
avons surtout pris identifié les effets
sur nos abonnements
l'analyse interne des recrutements
opérés lors de cinq journées phares de
compétitions sportives sur lequel le
groupe a obtenu des ordonnances de
blocage à savoir le Top 14 la Champions
League la Formule 1 la moto GP la
première ligue a permis d'observer une
augmentation de 55% des recrutements sur
ces journées phares par rapport à 2021
il est bien sûr irréaliste d'attribuer
cette croissance du parc abonné
exclusivement aux facteurs de blocage
des sites mais ce dernier a
nécessairement contribué à l'évolution
positive du nombre de recrutements la
concordance calendaire entre les
blocages opérés à quelques heures des
rencontres voir à quelques minutes des
rencontres comme le match PSG Real
Madrid ne peut avoir ne peut qu'avoir eu
pardon un impact positif sur la très
forte hausse de recrutement observée